hey guys it's just evening today you may
notice that I am sort of in my office
but not really in my office I've got a
lot of explaining to do but first we've
got something very very very exciting in
front of me this is the jellyfish by
LUMO forge hi Maddie do you know what
we're doing today did mommy get a new
server I think she did
okay let's unlock did I cut something
important oh wow now this is the
question that I have for myself so step
two fine friends okay
okay mate I gotta get this I gotta get
this out of here okay Maddie
that is so protected in there this is so
freaking cute how many people call
servers here so since this is sort of a
temporary office setup I'll show you
guys later down the line when I actually
have everything finished that I'm gonna
temporarily place it in here but the
good thing is it's actually not very
loud at all so it's really not gonna be
a big deal oh I've got a little notes to
family all right so here it is next up
we've got a few hard drives oh my
goodness oh gosh Matthew inside of here
or hard drives game of your face please
I am definitely handling it was extreme
care Oh so here's all of our drives and
now it's time to install we've got our
steps 1 2 3 finish unpacking done step 2
setup instructions and then I guess I
probably won't have any of that
questions so we're done it - we're gonna
put it over here for the time being
until we find you your permanent home I
kind of like looking at you like you
look good so the reason that I'm moving
it now is because I put all these hard
drives in it's gonna be really heavy wow
it's like you were made for this spot ok
so we're gonna start well put with Drake
dude would he start from the bottom I'll
start from the top so we have 120
terabytes and there will be 80 useable
[Music]
it's really fun that's right yeah look
at that wasn't it great fun you would do
another one that's what little sisters
are for you have to disguise it as like
a really fun task well I want to do this
one so I think maybe next year at CES
you guys should do a race to see who can
put the drives in the fastest I used to
participate in the computer building
race do you remember that Oh
my only goal was to not come in last I
used to build PCs back in the day guys I
know it's hard to believe but hold on
the life from high school are you ready
[Music]
that was so incredible Oh like little
fingers and that's it we've got our to
spare drives so I'll put those somewhere
safe
oh wait what's my next step plug it in
yeah I definitely get a battery backup
[Music]
perfect circle tolls my favorite van so
I've been just like getting my tool fix
oh you gonna come see this look at this
look what I'm doing back to a super
riveting I'm about to plug in the power
cable are you ready for this you guys
are I enjoyed it
on we have liftoff we're on to our next
step
super simple we basically are plugging
in this cat 7 cable into the back of the
jellyfish and then into my iMac Pro so
sit down if you're not sitting down
already and now we're installing the
jellyfish op depo that was that was
staged it's - its installed all right
here we go auto setup configuring my
connection and that's it that's
absolutely so that's it we did it we set
it up can I change the name of it it is
booted up we've got the ID jellyfish was
what I renamed it to on the desktop so
I'm gonna show you guys how quick and
easy this is I'm gonna move in one of my
project files and it is copying it over
but while that's happening we're going
to set up my macbook so we've got this
thunderbolt ethernet adapter here we're
gonna plug this in don't mind my cord
management this is temporary I say that
and then it's here like the remote it's
mounted oh my goodness this is so
exciting there is my $2,000 iPhone case
project file it's also over here so here
it is this is running directly off the
server
wow this is so exciting what's great
about this is Jenna and I both want to
be able to edit and I also want to
expand my team so being able to have
something that multiple people can work
off of is gonna be so amazing so it has
been a few days since I had my server
installed and I'm so excited about it
because I've been editing the past few
videos that I posted here in my channel
directly off of that server and it's
been it so fast it's also been really
great because Jenna now has sort of her
own section of it Jenna we're gonna add
a share here Jenna fish it's for you
so we both are editing
videos at the same time off of the same
server being able to transfer files
easily and sometimes they'll be
something where she's like hey can you
take a look at this I have a question
and I'm able to actually just have her
close her project file I open it up with
my computer I can make the edit close it
she can open it and basically just
continue where I left off I felt like I
had to do kind of a wrap up to what you
guys just saw because I was editing and
I was like hold on a second I kind of
just was all over the place unboxing and
I wanted to give you guys some specs and
answer a few questions that you guys
might have but I am so excited because
this year is definitely the year that I
need to build up my team because I'm
still editing and shooting a lot of
these videos myself and it takes a lot
of time so for me to continually grow
and actually keep myself sane and
healthy if they get something that needs
to be a priority and building out the
team having someone be able to help me
edit is gonna be a huge huge help
so that's something that I'm super
excited about and that core part of that
is being able to have a central place to
store all of that footage and also be
able to edit simultaneously off of so
this current configuration that I have
right now that you saw me set up has
eight 10 Gigabit Ethernet ports and it
has 8 1 Gigabit Ethernet ports there's a
hundred and 20 terabytes total and 79 of
those are usable so there's 20 total
hard drives installed and 4 of those
drives can fail before you lose any data
at all it also has 256 equilibrium and
two solid-state drives and as I need
more storage which I mean potentially
maybe if I start shooting everything at
8k this can actually expand to 480
terabytes they also have even larger
towers that can be expanded up to one
petabyte which is a lot of storage also
a lot of you guys were asking what
happened to the other server that I have
and I still have it and I still use it
so with that I have basically all of my
old archived footage on I have
everything from when I first started
making YouTube videos what I'm excited
about with the jellyfish is that this is
something that is going to be mostly
worked directly off of for editing and
it is basically made as a really great
workflow for teams and especially teams
using Final Cut as you guys know I am a
huge Final Cut fan so I guess my editing
background I guess goes back to college
so I think I first started editing in
Premiere in like 2004 which is a really
long time ago
from premier that I also did like
after-effects I also was into 3d so I
did 3d studio max I did Maya after that
I got a graphic design job and from the
graphic design job I went and got an
editing job editing Ava's guy was like
hey do you know how to edit out but I
was like yeah of course I do right out
of college thinking I can figure out
avid so then I taught myself final cut
in 2005 and then 2006 I started my
YouTube channel and then I've been final
cut ever since one final cut ten kind of
all switched over a lot of people kind
of jumped I'm so happy that I did
because I really love final cut I love
the interface I love the work flow and
for what I do like I feel like it is
honestly perfect anyway I just wanted to
wrap up this unboxing video I'm so
excited about this server I'll be giving
you guys another update on how I'm using
it and definitely I would love to give
you a look into my workflow I'm trying
to simplify it a little bit and kind of
make it more work-friendly for other
people because when I'm editing myself
like I kind of just throw everything in
a folder and I'm like I'm done I've got
this but when you're working with a team
and other people there needs to be some
sort of standard workflow so that
everyone is kind of working off of that
same thing so that is definitely
something that I am working on and
trying to figure out what the best most
efficient way is so if you guys have any
suggestions I would absolutely love to
hear those feel free to leave them in
the comments below or actually is
probably even easier if you just tweet
it to me because that would also be
super helpful a lot of the times most of
the tips and tricks that I've learned
like in Final Cut
it's just word of mouth like someone
would see me doing something and they're
like hey here's a better way to do that
well see you guys in my next video and
don't forget to subscribe so you'll see
more videos and also hit that Bell too
so you know
when actually post Celia
[Music]